Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today is an episode of Rawkode Live, a
show where we take a look at open
source projects that are joined by contributors and
maintainers,
and people that work for the companies that
power the open source to show you lots
of cool and interesting things.
And today, we are doing a follow-up to
the Teleport course where we're taking a look
to see what is new in Teleport 10.
How they manage to ship so many releases
so frequently, I'm not entirely sure, but we're
gonna cover all of the goodness that has
came out just this week.
And I'm
going to be joined by a friendly face
we've seen before, Ben Abbott. Hey, man. How's
it going?
Good. Thanks for having me, David. Always a
pleasure. Happy to have you here. For anyone
who hasn't seen our previous streams together, can
you give us a little bit of an
introduction into who is Ben?
Yeah. Hi. I'm Ben Arendt. I'm a developer
relations manager at Teleport.
And, actually, I've been at Teleport three years.
So I think I've seen it just from
three to ten. And so in a similar
trajectory. We've actually got more mature in our
deployment cycle. And so we only
we now launch new versions every three months.
So it keeps David up to date. And
I'm really excited to sort of go over
Teleport 10 and some of changes that we
have in this release, which
we always say each release is our biggest
release ever and just keeps on getting bigger
and bigger.
Yeah. When I started my Teleport course, I'm
pretty sure we're Teleport five or six, and
now we're already on to 10. Like, there's
so many cool new features coming out all
the time. So it's really nice that we
get to sit down together and just kinda
share these with people as well.
Yeah.
Yeah. And I think,
you know, just like a meta side point,
like,
as we've become more mature, we have, a
good upgrading page, but always important to keep
your software updated with latest patches. And we
do do security patches on older ones,
and we have sort of specific documentation around
how to upgrade between nine and ten and,
like, end of life cycle. So I think
you are still fine running Teleport seven in
production because
more mature organizations,
you know, it takes time to roll out
the latest ones. But I'm excited to a
deep dive into Teleport 10 and all of
the interesting new additions that we have.
Yeah. I'm I'm sitting here going through my
head trying to work out whether I call
it the fact that you said do do
or not, but I I'm gonna leave it
at just that. So
you're not even laughing. That that was funny.
I
actually didn't get it. Think it's accent.
Scottish.
Scottish jokes already.
Five
minutes in. Alright. It's all good.
Okay. So Teleport is continually shipping. I think
it's important to call it. Yeah. Like, they're
moving at c month velocity of releases, but,
you know, for most organ or for certain
enterprise sized organizations, you may not be moving
at the exact same pace as Teleport, but,
you know, there's a lot of I'm assuming
all of your releases are covered for a
certain
amount of time. Like, people on Teleport seven,
as you said, are still supported. They're still
getting security patches and so forth. So that's
really cool. Maybe
we
should start with a bit of a summary
then of what Teleport 10
brings to the table. You said it's the
your biggest release yet. What
what what have we got on Teleport 10
then?
Yeah. So I think our sort of
landmark feature for Teleport 10 is passwordless access
as a
sort of
new like, it is an authentication method for
Teleport, you know, get into the UI and
the CLI. But it also, I think, goes
beyond just
a new fancy authentication method, and it's really
our push to try to remove passwords from
infrastructure.
And when we talk about passwords at Teleport,
we're mainly talking about
things that
like, one, like, they may be passwords, but
they're also, like, long lived secrets. And so
let's say when you set up SSH as
an example, the first thing you do is
you, like, turn off password based authentication,
and you add public private key authentication.
But the private key is also a secret,
which is almost kinda like a password. And
so it's also open to attacks of,
like, exfiltration.
It's also relatively long lived. It could be,
like, hard to cycle.
And so, you know, Teleport solved that problem
initially by just
creating a
certificate
CA.
Yes. Not certificate authority
for
your, like, SSH certs, which you can do
with open SSH.
But open if you manage your own certificate
authority,
it can be difficult to do the data
operations such as the rotation, the management,
if you want to back it by a
HSM or other device.
All of that is sort of on you
to manage and maintain.
Mhmm.
And as we've sort of strengthened the certificate
authority, we've also looked to strengthen,
you know, and remove the password from the
end user.
And so the passwordless access,
well, obviously, has no password. It also has
no username
as well.
And both the user it's username less and
password less. So the experience
for an end developer is
during the registration process, you register your device,
whether it's a
touch ID with Mac, it could be a
like a YubiKey, which I have here,
or it could be Windows Hello.
And all of these passwordless devices
combine
some form of, like, biometrics. So you have,
like, Touch ID on Mac, but also the
secure
Encave on Mac or TPM
on
Windows.
And it's that combination of
that passwordless access, which is sort of also
kinda, like, hidden from you,
supports this sort of new flow
of Yeah. Access infrastructure.
Yeah. You're you're right. We're in a very
gray age of personal computing where we do
have the secure enclave on our Mac, and
we have TPMs, we've got YubiKeys, and all
these other things that try to improve our
security. And it's nice that we're kind of
seeing Teleport go on a on a journey.
Was it Teleport nine? You brought out machine
ID and the ability to kinda improve that
machine to machine communication,
and now you're removing the passwords from the
human element of it as well,
which is cool. Is it I I have
I might be
very naive here. Is this using web auth
end? Is that what powers the passwordless approach
for Teleport?
Yeah. It's you know, we added
web auth end in,
I think, Teleport nine, and we moved off
U2F.
And actually, we joined the FIDO Alliance,
which is sort of a industry body for
generally, we were moving,
like, moving to passwordless.
And
I forget we have, like, a blog post
coming on all the technical stages that
differ between, like, web app then. And, actually,
I'm thinking of working one too because
a lot of the work has been done
focused on clients and browsers,
but not necessarily that much on developer tooling.
And,
you know, we let's to support Touch ID
in the Mac in the terminal requires us
to use certain changes in our build. And
so, actually, if you use touch ID on
Mac, you see if you're using if you
have, like, the touch bar, you actually, like,
see
the Teleport icon because it's also to make
it work on Mac, it has to be,
like, specially notarized for it to work. So
we've done a whole bunch of work behind
the scenes. But for the end user experience,
you just, like, tap the thing, and it
just sort works out of the box. Very
cool. Now I'm sure you're not prepared for
this question, but I feel the urge to
ask it anyway.
So will it work with my Apple Watch?
Because I can, like, fiddle my privileges with
my Apple Watch, and I'm wondering if that
prompt is gonna come to it, and I
could log in to my machines with my
watch. That would make me very happy then.
We were chatting about this actually, like, the
day after the release,
and I think it should work. I Alan,
who did the development on it, has, a
dev build. Yeah.
He doesn't have an Apple Watch. So
I'm excited to try it. I mean, I've
tried actually have like a Logitech webcam here.
Well,
you had one. No. I had one. This
one.
And what's kind of interesting with
the webcam is like the password, the, like,
the biometrics
in it isn't on the camera. It's actually
in the infrared sensor, which is why you
need an extra camera.
Ah, okay.
So it's not just like your face. I
think it has like a IR array that
measures sort of depth and other details to
make the biometrics more secure.
I don't know if you like, Windows Hello
is actually pretty awesome if you own the
Windows ecosystem.
I'm afraid Lennox and Mac is is is
all I use, really. I do think what
they've done with Windows 11 is quite cool,
and I keep trying I I keep meaning
to install it on an old machine and
and play with WSL two more, but it's
just time. I just haven't had the time.
Yeah. I've not tried it, but with the
announcement,
someone said Windows Hello did work with Windows
subsystem of Linux as well. And so support
is pretty broad. Yeah.
And I think before we dive too deep,
you know,
one of the things that sort of fixes
is there's a sort of whole range of
attacks that sort of go away.
There's no longer any cookie to take. You're
not open to phishing.
You you know, it just removes, like, password
reuse and all these other sort of problems.
Yeah.
I think we're both fan and Surrounding Technologies
and the work of the FIDO Alliance is
is is awesome because, you know, I I
can you know, my in laws, my parents,
my wife, my friends, none of them use
password managers. They just use the same password
everywhere. It's very common. At least, maybe I
I don't know. It it feels like in
my life and the people I know, it's
very common where they just have these crappy
passwords. And but they can all use the
fingerprint scanner or the biometric face scanner for
Apple Wallet and Google Pay and stuff. So,
like, the more that we push these secure
biometric devices to be the way that we
identify with web services and other services. I
think this is really, really important for securing
all of this stuff. So
Yeah. And
the Fighter Alliance or Google,
Microsoft,
and Apple came with pass keys,
which is sort of another variant on passwordless,
which you'll probably be seeing more of. But
passkeys are sort of interesting because a lot
of the key it's good for your, let's
say, your parents, but a lot of the
key material also goes into, like, a central
Apple server. And so you can use passkeys
across
operating systems and across browsers,
which has kind of been a slow transition.
But
for sort of infrastructure companies, you may not
necessarily want your, like, IDP to be one
of the big three, let's say.
And I think that's kind of where having,
like, YubiKeys, for example, are a great
solution for it. Yeah.
Alright. We do have a question in the
chat from Kartik.
And I think I'll probably be able to
get the answer to this, but they're asking
how do I upgrade to Teleport 10?
Now I'm hoping that they've just added the
app repository,
and they can just run an app upgrade.
Right? Is that the the easiest way?
Yes. We have a full upgrade procedure, so
we do recommend backing up,
you know, backing up your auth server, any
other logs just as a
standard practice.
You know, if you have a fresh cluster,
if you just do a standard app, you'll
just get Teleport 10 out of the box.
And actually, we have versioned it now. So
you can go online on nine or 10,
and you can pick your streams to automatically
upgrade those versions because it was Sure. It
used to previously pick the previous one. So
it's another nice sort of developer experience.
But, yeah, to check out documentation, we have
docs on sort of how to upgrade it.
But, generally, it's pretty much drop and
go. You should be fine.
Alright. There is, like, if you change like,
if you look at our release notes, we
have
probably some depreciated things. Like, if you're using
a u two f, that's depreciated intent. But
these are mainly, like, edge cases that you
will unlikely to encounter.
Alright. So we still got more stuff to
talk about this new Intelliport 10. Before we
do that, we'll just handle a couple of
the hellos.
Thanks for joining us.
Rawkode is here too, and Eddie is interested
in Apple Watches everywhere. So awesome. Hey. Eddie's
trying to do my job for me now.
He's like, hey. Everyone should follow-up this video.
Yeah. You totally should. Please I know. I
mean, I think I'm going to get Eddie
in the future, so I think we'll get
the Apple Watch build for Eddie. And,
actually, I was trying on my iPad too,
but I wasn't able to register my face
ID, but that should technically work as well.
Sweet. Well, lots of things to experiment with
there. Now
there's more things in this release, and I
do have the watch new IntelliPortem blog here.
So maybe we could scroll through this, and
you can give us a bit of a
an introduction to the other stuff that's listed
here. So we've covered password list. I don't
know if there is anything else you wanna
add or we'll skip right past this, but
there's also a nice little video there where
people could check that out too.
The next thing on the list, and I'll
make this a little bit bigger for people,
is enhanced access control. You wanna give us
a little bit of information on this?
Oh, you still there?
I'm on my own.
Ben, don't leave me, Ben.
We'll get Ben just a moment. I hope
he comes back.
Alright. Well, while we wait for Ben, we
have an active Discord server. If you want
to come and chat technology with over 1,200
people, you can join a Academy Discord. It's
available at Rawkode.chat.
We have channels on Kubernetes,
Cloud Native, Teleport, Pulumi, GetOp, Continuous Delivery, Rust,
Contrail, one of my open source projects.
We're just a group of people that just
love to sit and talk about technology. So
feel free to pop into the Rawkode Academy
Discord at Rawkode.chat.
And as Eddie said in the comments, remember
to sum up the video.
We're hoping that Ben will be back in
just a minute because he was gonna drive
the demo. However, if we need to, I
will make up my own demo. I do
have
a single load Teleport cluster ready and waiting
for me to try and work out how
to enable password authentication with my Apple Watch.
So
can't you leave? I can't believe he left
me, Ben.
He's not coming back, is he?
Alright.
So let's see what is enhanced access control.
Well, apparently, this is resource access request and
preview.
This is just in time access request to
allow any developer to request access to a
resource or role depending on the need. Oh,
nice. So this is something that I think
was maybe available previously
in Teleport.
I'm not sure if it's just been modified
in some way, but when you give a
user a certain amount of scope or access
to your cluster, there may be occasions where
maybe you don't get them production access and
they have to be able to elevate their
privileges.
And there was a really cool system in
Teleport where you can request access to the
elevated privileges and someone else has to approve
it or two people have to approve it,
and then you get this window.
I think it's configurable thirty minutes to one
hour where you have the production access.
So
not sure what the change is here.
And it is enterprise only, which is a
shame. It's a very cool feature.
Oh, wait. Another enterprise only feature. IP based
restrictions and certificates. I guess I can understand
the urge there. You wanna make sure that
only certain IP addresses have access to Teleport
cluster because it protects all the stuff.
Exactly.
Well, that's a feature. I was very excited
when I read about this in the blog
post and it's on Teleport community, which is
awesome.
But this is automatic Linux user provisioning.
So this creates
a local Linux user for your Teleport user,
which wasn't
a thing. This was actually a really common
cause of frustration for me personally as that
I was always like, when I was creating
users or setting up users, I would always
do, like, the t t control,
Teleport control,
users add roles, and I'd give myself admin
when that was a thing, but now other
or editor and access.
But I'd always forget the dash dash logins
to actually get some access to the users
within the machine and that removes
that problem,
which is very, very cool. So I'm looking
forward to being able to play with that.
We've got extended scope
for features of machine ID.
Alright. Okay. So machine ID for Kubernetes. This
is awesome. We covered machine ID on our
Teleport nine video.
So machine ID allows us to give shortlist
certificates to machine to machine communication based systems.
The the example here is is Ansible.
For me, Kubernetes was always the ideal target.
So it's nice to see that we've got
application
access preview there too.
We got machine ID rotation,
and I hope that Ben comes back and
he can describe some of this stuff because
I am absolutely winging it.
So the list that there's lots in this
blog, and if Ben isn't here in the
next one minute
oh, he just showed up. I was just
about to call you out, Ben.
I'm back.
Yeah. I'm not sure what happened. I was
just running through the release blog, then
reading the titles and pretending I knew what
half the features were, but I wasn't entirely
sure.
So
I'm very glad you're Power outage.
Power outage. Well, that could be forgiven. I'm
glad you're Yeah. And I
I'm over provisioned with Internet, and so I
had to turn on my second
I had to, like, manually fail over to
my second ISP.
So I'm back in action.
Well, I'm very glad that you're back.
So I was just basically saying that we
kinda covered passwordless,
I think we've given everyone a good idea
of that. I figured maybe you'd be happy
and excited to just give us a short
description on the other major features on this
release blog, and then maybe we can get
hands on and take a look at some
of these features on your cluster. That sound
good?
Can you still hear me? Yeah. So I
think
yep. Can hear Can you hear me? I
can. There's just a small amount of latency,
I guess, on your your new ISP, but
I'll I'll deal with it. It's all good,
man.
Okay.
Yes. Comcast. This is why it's one.
Alright. So, you wanna just text them or
do you want me to run through them
and you can say a few words. What
would you prefer?
I think I would just talk about three
main ones. Go for it.
And I think the three other ones beyond
passwordless
is our resource access requests.
And this really lets teams implement the privilege
of
the principle of least privilege
by creating an inventory of hosts that they
need to get access to.
And that sends a request to their team
in sort of chat ops. We have a
Slack integration,
and they can sort of approve it.
And that's sort a really powerful feature for
sort of larger teams, especially if you have
a very large inventory of hosts and you
wanna
give access to a few. This sort of
upgrades it from our previous release, which has
just role based access requests.
But sometimes within a let's say, role of,
like, DevOps, you might only need to access,
two hosts, and so this lets you do
that.
The second one is automatic user provisioning.
This is sort of a small addition,
but it's super
powerful.
It lets you
sort of, you know, create the user, create
sudoers. So instead of having one,
like, easy to user, you can just, you
know, use
your
login from your sort of IDP
automatically,
and so it just makes setup and configuration
much easier and gives you more control on
who can have sudo privileges without having to
set up the PAM stack yourself.
And the third one is sort of our
machine ID for Kubernetes.
I think this would probably interest you.
This lets you get short lived KubeConfigs
using machine ID.
And so if you would want to
have an automated tool run like a
security scanner in your Kubernetes cluster and you
would give it a KubeConfig,
this would be an example in which you
could issue those KubeConfigs
without having to worry about, you know, rotation,
connection, and auditing also built into it.
Awesome. Yeah. Though, actually, two of those features
were the ones I was kinda saying I
was most excited about when you were offline.
The automatic Linux user provision, I think, just
I used to make the mistake of setting
up my users all the time and forgetting
to provide the logins, and that would just,
like, break my experience. So I have to
go and edit that.
And, of course, machine ID for Kubernetes is
definitely right up my street. I'm looking forward
to be able to kick the tires on
that a little bit more. But, yeah, very
cool features here.
Alright. Should we shall I show you some?
I would love that. Let's do it.
Let's do it. So I share my screen.
Alright. You're good.
Okay. So
let me go to this login. You can
actually change this login. So
people
this is the new addition to Teleport 10.
So this is like the password less login.
And so let me
log in.
And it's sort of a similar prompt. Actually,
I don't think you can see their prompt
because
of the way in which the screen sharing
works, but I have a pop up that
says, like, pick your identity.
So I'm pick up USB key.
Hold on. Actually,
you know what? I have the other I
d wrench this one.
Let me get my I don't really need
show you, but my other USB keys. You
basically tapped your key.
I should get my other one because this
is like the hallmark feature. One sec.
That's funny.
Now
this is an interesting side problem with passwordless.
That generally is advised to have two YubiKeys
or you can register multiple devices.
You can register Touch ID and the YubiKey.
And so let's say if I go to
work and I forget my YubiKey, I can
still log in with Touch ID with passwordless.
And then you can also add multiple YubiKeys.
So you can always have one as a
backup as well, which I probably recommend.
If you move fully to this one. And
so
we
I don't think you can see it, but
it's asking me for which account to log
in as.
Nice. And then I'm logged in. And so
no
there's actually a window that you if you
have you can log register multiple users to
one
YubiKey.
And so I have a Teleport admin and
my other user. This is Mike, which is
one of my demo users.
And so you sort of change between them.
And that's sort of by which I said
it's user lameness. When you register them, they
get registered to,
let's say, the the resident key in YubiKey,
and that's how it is both passwordless and
usernameless.
And so that's question I've logged yeah. Yeah.
Oh, our latency just got much better. You
actually responded, like, immediately. That's awesome. Cool. Go
Comcast.
So
if I've got like, I I like to
set up GitHub
authentication
with my Teleport cluster so that I can
log in with that. Can I still add
those extra web off end keys,
touch ID, etcetera to that account, or is
it just completely separate account?
For the first version in preview, it's a
separate account,
but we're working on solutions to work with,
like, your IDP for passwordless
to sort of combine the user.
Alright. Nice. Cool.
And then this is sort of just an
example of when which I have, you know,
like, Touch ID, YubiKey, and Windows Hello, like,
all registered as different devices as sort of
as my backup.
Nice. I like that.
And, you know, the registration flow is kind
of the same for adding new users.
And then the user get like, depending upon
how you configure it, the user gets to
pick how they want to
enroll their password list option. So that's kind
of the flow for onboarding people. You send
people links and they register, and
they're onboarding on password list.
So let's go to the next thing we're
talking about was
actually gonna log out of Mike
and log back in as with GitHub.
Because when you might have seen this too.
So when you log in as GitHub, it
sort of brings in your, like, GitHub username,
which is, the internal user. Mhmm. You can
configure this. It could be, like, an email
address or something from your central, like, IDP
if you have Okta.
Without or so with automatic user creation, if
I just log in as Ben Arant,
it creates this user for me.
Because normally that Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Normally, it would fail, and then
you'd like, oh, it's like you don't have
access to this host.
And so sort of now it just works
sort of seamlessly out of the box. Yeah.
That's a great feature. It's like one of
those really strong quality of life improvements that
I think everyone's gonna be celebrating.
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely because it kinda trips people
up to start off with.
So that was the second one on my
hot list.
I think the third one is access
request feature.
And okay. Let me log out of me
my user.
Let me log in as Alice.
And Alice, when she logs in,
there's nothing here. So there's no servers,
no applications, no clusters.
But she has the ability to view
the inventory of hosts that are available to
her to find within a role. So let's
say she needs to debug
a few of these sort of worker nodes
and the Kubernetes cluster.
The sort of just in time access requests
let her build a inventory
of just the devices and nodes that she
needs access to.
And so
on
debug,
you can also request reviewers, but I'm just
gonna request this.
This goes out to a request.
My other user would sort of accept it.
You assume this role, and then you can
sort of just go about your day of
just using Teleport normally.
But, you know, we've really scoped down
all of we've given people the ability to
see inventory of resources,
but also greatly scoped down the sort of
access. And so this is a sort of
a nice sort of check.
You know, it can help with compliance, but
also help with just
not giving access to all of your infrastructure
at one time. So it can be, like,
a nice compliance and also a good security
feature.
Yeah. I love that feature. That's very cool.
I I I didn't really understand when I
was when you were offline, I was kinda
trying to understand the enhanced
role resource thing. And I didn't really pick
up on it, although Russell did in the
chat. But being able to individually pack those
resources instead of applying an entire role with,
like, the node selector and the Kubernetes selector
and stuff is a very, very cool feature.
There's another cool
addition to the if you
if you know the host you wanna access,
so let's say, I would like
SSH into one of these nodes and you
don't have access to it, in the command
line, it can also create the request for
you. And so you can have this whole
experience and flow without using the terminal,
which is sort of a very powerful, like,
addition.
Yep. You know, you don't have to come
into Teleport. You can just do it on
the CLI. And all these features, you know,
must be available on the CLI.
Yeah.
We have a question from Russell on the
chat if you're happy to pick that one
up while we log in. I'm assuming you're
gonna log in and approve Alice, so I'll
read the questions just now. But Russell is
asking if there's a way to drop a
session with machine ID. So assuming we give
access
to give a KubeConfig to somebody, but we
then want to revoke that sooner than the
expiration. Is that possible?
So you can so the answer to this
question, I believe, I might have to double
check on this. The
best practice is to really limit
your time. So you can have machine ID,
I think, go down to, like, the minute
or maybe, like, five minutes.
And then you can lock it.
And so the idea is you'll always issue
these certificates every five minutes,
but then we have, like, t guddle box
lock.
And then that will lock it from issuing
any new certs.
And so if you're worried about that sort
of window of attack, I would just reduce
the time in which you issue it from,
like, Teleport.
Yeah. That makes sense. That makes sense.
Think we have looked into revocation of certificates,
but I think it
is a sort of a complicated problem. So
we advise people just give certificates a really
short life and then use the ability to
lock it if you think a certificate has
been compromised.
I'm talking of sort of that realm of
certificates
being compromised.
We've added in
IP
based I forgot
the official name of the feature. Let me
look on the roles.
Pin source IP into roles.
And this means when someone uses TSH to
get their certificates,
it bakes in the source IP that requested
it. So
this is actually an interesting use case. I
just changed, like, ISPs.
So I probably have a different IP address
now.
And so my first if I was to
use the command line and issue the certificates,
it wouldn't work because my IP had changed.
I'd have to log in again to get
a certificate to match. Right. Right. Gotcha. Yeah.
That that makes a lot of sense. Like,
that
I think that removes a whole bunch of
attack vectors. Right? Because this one was the
source IP that made the initial request. So
if that changes, it's not something bad is
happening or potentially something bad is happening.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. ISP's gone down. So
it's like a nice little,
you know, security feature.
Cool.
Are you going to approve
Alice? Is that what we are?
I can approve Alice. I mean, the approval
flow
is sort of nice and we, you know,
you can have the reason
for approving.
You can have messages regarding and
then Alice will be able to sort of
go about her
her standard flow like you assumed.
I don't need to necessarily share that since
it's already, you know, kinda like standard
standard Teleport flow.
Russell likes the IP pending. Nice feature. Yeah.
I think we're all agreed on that one.
It's pretty good.
Yeah. That's another one within our sort of
what's new.
I think that we we have more information
here about the time bound. And I think
this is actually an enterprise only feature
since,
you know, if you have your home lab,
it's not you're unlikely to have a nation
stake trying to get your certificates.
Cool. Let me see what else we have
in here. And then I think, you know,
we've added a range of new databases
as well.
Snowflake being a pretty interesting one.
I think Snowflake's
interesting
because,
you know, it's
our other protocols have gone deep. So we
have to go, like, deep MySQL,
deep Postgres.
But, like, modern database is just over,
like, TCP, like, HTTP.
And
it's a sort of the same flow. You
can access your Snowflake cluster,
And all of this is done on the
command line, so you use just Snow SQL
as well as you stand as you would
normally.
And we also have additions
to
use, like, graphical tools for sort of Postgres
and MySQL as well. So you can issue
it to teams who don't wanna who aren't
that familiar with sort of the command line
tools.
Very cool.
There was quite a few new databases listed
on that log there. Right? I've seen Elasticsearch
and Elasticsearch
is coming. These are gonna be in 10/02.
This mem
these ones, I mean, I kinda think they're
the same. Like, they're both
Amazon's Redis compatibility
additions, like MemoryDB and ElasticCache for Redis. So
just providing more AWS cover.
And then, like, I guess, Cassandra is
coming in 10/03. And so, you know, we're
just always adding more databases.
So if you, you know, have one that
you're sort of interested in, definitely
search our GitHub issues
if there's a ticket for it. Or if
not, you know, create an issue.
Nice.
Most of these ones are also quite easy.
Like, once we had our Redis integration, it's
easy to add MemoryDB because it's just speaks
Redis, but there's just a few nuances of
how they have
set up their authentication.
Yeah. So how many databases does Teleport support
now?
I imagine that's quite a large number.
I don't know the official number, but the
documentation page for databases is growing. And
it also,
you know, we've kind of, like, deep on
the different cloud vendors. So, like, AWS,
RDS,
GCP,
like SQL, MySQL.
Active Directory SQL,
we added in audit logging as an addition,
which wasn't previously available for Microsoft SQL.
And, actually, we're writing, a blog post. I
guess it could be difficult for some people
to access Microsoft SQL on Linux as well.
So, also,
if you do have to use it and
you're Linux native, you know, it's sort of
a nice tool for accessing Microsoft SQL.
And then Cockroach, she has another one that
we added. So you're just always adding and
expanding.
And we also try to so we have,
like, self hosted MongoDB,
but also MongoDB Atlas.
And so we support sort of DBAs as
a service as well as self self hosted
databases.
Yeah. MongoDB
Atlas released serverless databases earlier this year. And,
like, the free tier is actually
really interesting. I started using it for a
few things. And gotta say it's it's just
a pleasant experience. And I I actually didn't
know I could throw Teleport in front of
that. So I'm even happier now that I
can.
Yeah. The setup and configuration is also
pretty simple because, you know, they run your
database.
Often, the process
is
exporting a sort of x five zero nine
certificates,
adding it into your, like, MongoDB Atlas cluster
and registering the user.
And that's pretty much it. So it's pretty
if you already have a cluster set up,
the configuration and setup is relatively simple. You
know, you have the self managed x five
zero nine, and you create the user that
has the certificates,
and that's pretty much it. So it's
if you have a class three already, it's
a pretty nice and smooth experience.
Alright. That's tomorrow's mission then.
Yeah. They'll keep going down. So in the
desktop access, this one is gonna be really
exciting. This one's in ten two, but I've
seen a preview of it.
It you know, we added we've added Windows
desktops,
but this lets you
share local files over the browser.
And so you could have directories
and
we added clipboard support.
Hopefully, this
works. So it's already, like, natively sort of
passwordless. But if you wanted to sort drag
files into here from my Mac operating system,
it's
a pain. And
this
directory sharing is sort of a cool addition.
It uses a sharing API over, like, TDP,
which is sort of our RDP protocol.
It's super
interesting sort of solution to the problem, but
it's also all in the browser.
And I've not seen much else that's sort
of similar in the browser without, like, having
a native client. So
the guys have done a great job on
this.
I can just drag a file from my
Mac onto a Windows machine via the browser.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah.
Yeah. Pretty cool. And then when it's trying
to simplify setup, you know, desktop
support is may you know, people managing their
own, like, self managed ID currently. So mainly
large organizations who are worried about security, so
we make configuration a little easier.
Alright.
And then I think also this is sort
of in ten one, like,
just generic
application support for sort of WebSocket connections
and different protocols. So just sort of expanding
application access as well.
So this brings support for m p p
p.
Yeah. Yep.
Thanks. I like that. And so this was
first read through, like, a open issue. And
so this is sort of, I guess, showing,
like, Teleport sort of open core, open source
sort of nature. So, you know, if there's
a certain feature that you wanna get, you
know, like,
this is from February, so we've worked on
this, like, relatively quicker, which sort of shows
the philosophy of the team is always ramping
up.
Yeah. I like that.
And there's other so the proxy peering is
just
makes your cluster come, like, faster.
And then I think this is we've sort
of interesting for you
is our Kubernetes
operator and moving away from persistent volumes.
There's some other
So what's the operator
thing? Sorry. What what what's it bringing here?
Let me get you the docs for the
operator.
Me.
Oh, I don't have the docs for the
operator.
The operator
does let you configure Teleport
in a more streamlined way
Nice.
With for creating users and using TCuddle
and sort of extending it without having to
sort of customize YAML as much or modify
our home charts.
Yeah. Trying to pass properties and configuration into
the home chart has proven cumbersome time and
time again. So relying more on custom resources
and being able to apply them to the
cluster. Yeah. Again, something else I'm gonna have
to start kicking the tires on. I think
that's gonna simplify my own infrastructure a good
fair bit. So that's nice to see.
Yeah. I think it would definitely help you
a lot with clustered.
And I think this would be ten one.
So soon you'll be able to try this
out.
Nice. And removal of the persistent volume. So
where's all the state live?
That is a good question. And
let me find the issue because I I
knew you'd ask me that question.
And
like everything that we do and along with
kind of being open call for GitHub,
we have sort of RFDs.
Ah. We sort of discuss like how we're
implementing our features.
And so,
you know, it sort of describes the problem
and sort of, like, tokens and the problems
that we've run into
and sort of how we've gone about building
it. So we're just using Kubernetes native secrets.
Very cool. Yeah. So if anyone's sort of
really interested in it, this sort of goes
through, like, our thought process, like, what it
changes,
how it works. We sort of flowcharts, and
as you can see, it's always
other edge cases, like dealing with, like, CA
rotations,
you have to take into account and sort
of other limitations of it.
Sort of upgrade procedures, change to a helm
charts.
So this is also a great resource if
you wanna get a head start on the
on the feature.
Yeah. I'll share that link in the description
below once we finish for today.
And I think that's it. You know, we're
working on making upgrades easier. You know, lots
of people talked about upgrades.
I think we're gonna first start with nodes
and less sort of a notification procedure to
know which nodes is sort of out of
date and
then probably move to a more automatic upgrading
of clusters
for people.
Mhmm.
Alright. But I think that is,
you know, that is it. Just a small
release. Just those 1,200
features. That's that's all that is. That's fine.
And other bug fixes. So in our, like,
Teleport 10, we've sort of given people more
preview to ones that are coming in different
minor releases.
But I think we're gonna be releasing ten
one in a couple of weeks.
And so that would also mean that we'll
upgrade Teleport Cloud instances as well.
Cool.
Alright. Well, those are some pretty cool features.
I hope people are excited by that. If
you have any questions for Ben, now is
a good time to drop them into the
chat as we'll be finishing shortly.
I see we have one from Russell. And
before we tackle that, I'm gonna pop us
back over
the big facey mode. There we go.
So Russell is asking if
any of the databases
support session recording.
Yeah.
Or sorry. It says do all databases support
session recording, or is it dependent on the
database thing?
All of them support
audit logging,
not necessarily session recording
due to the nature of them. And, actually,
if you look at our audit logs,
what's sort of interesting is because it's sort
of such a low level of the protocol,
when you run, like, a get tables, it
sort of shows you what's the raw input
interpreted to the database.
And
because you can make, like, multiple requests to
the database at one time, that's sort of
in our order log, but it doesn't sort
of play back in the session recording mode.
If you did want to get
session recording for what people are to your
databases,
probably what I recommend would be
create a Teleport server and then use that
Teleport server
with sort of MySQL or SQL tools. Then
you can see both what are people doing
with
the their sort of, like, SQL commands.
You can play that back, but you also
get the full audit log of what's happening
on the host itself.
I think that's sort of similar to what
you do at cluster, isn't it? You have
one VM that people share their
Kubernetes session.
We
have
three bare metal machines
and we use Teleport SSH amongst them all
and people join the active sessions so we
can all type.
Yes. Kind of And then you get a
cube config and then, like, share that kind
of cube config in that in that way
regard.
Yeah. The cube config is available on the
control plane node and we just export an
environment variable so we can all share that.
Yeah.
Not very sophisticated. We we should leverage more
Teleport features there and hook it in to
the cluster. But by the challenge with cluster
is that people break the clusters, so we
can't Teleport
has to stay away from it, really. Right?
Otherwise, we lose access. Yeah. So we keep
Teleport in a nice little box. The golden
rule is do not break Teleport.
Break everything else, so I I I probably
can't push more of the tell the Kubernetes
features because of that reason. Would be nice,
though.
Okay. So Russell said, sorry. I used the
wrong terminology. I meant audit events. So, yes,
that is supported. Oh, yeah. Everything has audit
events.
And
the only one that didn't have it recently
was the Microsoft SQL Server, but we added
that in 10.
There we go. Another feature in 10 that
we didn't cover. Lots of them. So
alright. It looks like there's any more questions.
Russell says thank you. I'll say thank you
to Ben. It's always a pleasure to have
you join us.
Lots of things to say here with Teleport
ten.
I'm gonna have to upgrade my infrastructure now
as well.
And as the new features drop, we'll be
sure to get more content on Teleport on
the channel, and I'm sure we'll be back
in three months for Teleport 11. So any
last words, Ben, before I let you get
back to your to your day?
Nope. That's it. Thanks for joining everyone. If
you have any questions, you know, you can
join our community Slack channel.
It's avail it's a scoteleport.com
forward slash slack.
But I'm pretty sure most of you guys
are already there, and I'm happy to answer
any questions that come up.
Alright. Thanks a lot. Have a good day,
everyone. Thank you, Ben. I'll see you soon.
Bye.